each of us how do we actually build our
own personal Brands because that's what
takes us forward that's what gives us
the reason to wake up every day and
that's an important part so you want to
talk about that
absolutely so it so it starts with why
um uh a y is fundamentally An Origin
story
where you come from
all of us our why is fully formed
uh by the time we're in our mid to late
teens because we are all products of how
we grew up the experiences we had when
we were young molded us into who we are
today and you are who you are there's no
changing Who You Are the question is
whether you're making decisions that are
in balance with who you are out of
balance we call that stress or we call
it flow if it works in the right
direction
so I can give you
a simple and fun little exercise that
will help you learn your why it may not
be exact but it'll get you in the
ballpark right
find a friend you love and who loves you
the kind of friend who you know you
could call them at three o'clock in the
morning and if they called you three
o'clock in the morning you'll be there
for them do not do this with a spouse do
not do this with a sibling do not do
this with a parent those relationships
are too close and they think they know
everything about you already right do it
with a best friend
and ask them this simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy
because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings like love and
loyalty and Trust the limbic brain
doesn't control language so we struggle
to put those feelings into words
but then ironically you actually stop
asking the question why because the
question why is an emotional question we
need rational answers so you say come on
What specifically is it about me
that I know you would be there for me no
matter what and they'll struggle I don't
know of course they know they just don't
have the part of the brain that controls
language I don't know they'll say uh and
they'll start describing you
uh you're honest uh you're always there
for me when I need you and you'll have
to play Devil's Advocate you have to say
that's just the definition of a friend
What specifically is it about me that I
know you'd be there for me no matter
what don't help them don't let anybody
help them let them go through the stress
and they'll go through this process a
few times why are you asking me this I
don't know and eventually they'll give
up and eventually
they'll start talking about themselves
and this is what my friend said to me I
don't know Simon all I know is that I
can sit in a room with you I don't even
have to talk to you and I get inspired
and I got goosebumps in fact I'm getting
them right now because what they said
what they articulated was the reason
that the the value I feel in their lives
that's what they said
and the reason I had an emotional
response is because that's my why and if
you do it with multiple friends which I
did you get almost the exact answer
because your why is the thing you give
to the world when you're operating at
your natural best
and it's the value you have in people's
lives whether they're your friends or
your teammates
so you can go through this exercise it's
a lot of fun it'll help you get get in
in the in the ballpark and then then the
only thing is you have to learn to start
with why